[Musique]
elle est un bien précieux notre poumon
vert une réserve de
biodiversité avec ses 17 millions
d'hectares la forêt française est un
maillon essentiel de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est le
deuxième puit de carbone après les
océans mais notre forêt
souffre
elle est en danger menacé par les effets
du réchauffement climatique par les
sécheresses à répétition et la rapidité
de ces
bouleversements en 10 an la mortalité
des arbres a augmenté de 80 %. leur
croissance a considérablement ralenti et
la capacité de nos forêts à stocker du
carbone
diminue un défi
majeur comment réinventer la forêt la
sauver pour qu'elle nous
[Musique]
sauve au cœur de la Côte d'Or au nord de
Dijon le domaine de Jie une forêt de
grand être présente ici depuis la
dernière glaciation il y a 10000 ans
alors voilà c'est làicici avec les
collègues qu'on a repéré quand même
beaucoup de dépérissement sur le massif
donc c'est pour ça qu'on voulait vous le
[Musique]
montrerin il manque vraiment plein de
feuilles en haut sur les branches elles
sont toutes rouge ils ont vraiment
souffert là et puisas plein de branches
mortes dans dans le ha pied enfin tu tu
vois bien que ça va pas s'améliorer à la
saison prochaine quoi et moins t de
feuilles moins t de chance que ça
redémarre bien au
printemps Lilian du banc et Brigitte
musche sont spécialiste du changement
climatique à l'Office National des
Forêts après un nouvel été caniculaire
il viennent constater les
dégâts ce qui est dur à vivre c'est
quand même qu'on voit là des êtres
principalement qui sont là depuis des
générations d'arbres des centaines
d'années bah qui arrivait très bien à
pousser ici et là on on voit qu' il n'y
arrive plus quoi les choses ont vraiment
commencé en 2018 mais ne font que
s'implifier depuis les êtres ne résiste
plus aux canicules et surtout aux
sécheress à
répétition le sol est tellement sec
qu'ils n'ont plus assez d'eau pour
amener la sève jusqu'à leurs feuilles on
voit que en quelques années suffit de
quelques années pour que Ben un arbre
qui a mis plus de 100 ans à pousser
meurt et là donc c'est l'arbre qui meurt
c'est l'accueil qui pouvait faire
un certain nombre d'espèces c'est le
carbone qu'il était capable de stocker
parce qu'un grand arbre comme ça faut
l'imaginer avec toutes ses feuilles il
peut vraiment capter du carbone là voilà
il en capte presque plus et puis de
toute façon quand il va mourir il va le
relarguer ce carbone on voit que le bois
est à disons en proie aux éléments et
ben il se dégrade et on va on va avoir
du mal à le valoriser pour en faire des
meubles par exemple donc c'est vraiment
enfin c'est plus qu'une double peine
c'est c'est de la peine sur tous les
rôles que jouent les arbres dans les
dans dans l'écosystème et pour nous
aussi humains un sacré pépère la
parcelle la quasi totalité des arbres va
mourir et c'est ça qui est dur pour nous
c'est s'il y avait une espèce bon voilà
c'est une espèce parce que il y a une
maladie particulière mais non là avec
les changements climatiques sécheresse
canicule tout tout l'écosystème n'est
pas adapté à ce climat là et c'est ça
qu'on c'est ça qu'on dont on voit les
conséquence quelques kilomètres plus
loin une autre espèce est attaquée les
épicéas meurent les uns après les autres
décimés en quelques mois par un
insecte on voit voit que c'est en cours
ouais h en même temps avec la chaleur
qui fait là fin septembre les conditions
sont réunies pour qu'ils
attaquent cet insecte ah voilà c'est le
scolite là il a creuser sa galerie pour
pondre c'est tout petit hein ça fait 2
mm de long et ensuite les larves Hop qui
se nourrissent en mangeant euh la partie
du bois qui est juste sous les cors et
les petites larves sont là toutes
blanches he toutes blanches donc elles
avec les chaleurs qui fait encore elles
vont continuer leur croissance et cetera
et comme l'hiver il fait plus
suffisamment froid pour les geler et les
faire mourir elles vont aller attaquer
d'autres épicéas l'année
prochaine regardez les lar qui tombent
là il est complètement infesté et
pourquoi les scolit il se développe
autant que ça euh ils sont favorisés par
les températures et là ils devrait pas
être aussi actifs que ça une fin
septembre et les arbres ils sont trop
stressés ils arrivent plus à se défendre
et donc là voilà c'est il y a vraiment
peu de choses qu'on peut
faire affaibli par la sécheresse les
épicéas n'ont plus assez de résine pour
se défendre ici encore c'est toute la
parcelle qui va
mourir on est très inquiet pour l'avenir
nous les forestiers parce que ben on
voit les arbres qui sont en train de
mourir enfin tous les jours avec les
collègues on est en forêt et et ce qu'on
voit c'est les attaque du du changement
climatique et d'année en année c'est
pire c'est comme une une boule de neige
qui qui grossit et qui
[Musique]
grossit la forêt est affaiblie par le
réchauffement climatique mais pas
seulement aujourd'hui des pratiques
forestières sont remises en question
accusé de fragiliser la forêt comme la
monoculture pour des raisons économiques
pour développer la filière bois et la
rentabiliser dans certaines régions des
massifs entiers ont été plantés avec une
seule
espèce quand les arbres de ces
plantations linéaires arrivent à
maturité ils sont tous coupés en même
temps laissant le sol à nu c'est la
coupas c'est ce qui s'est passé dans le
Morvent le problème ça commencé dans les
années 70 c'est quand là justement euh
le le l'état estimé que la balance
commerciale de pour la forêt était en
déficit donc a incité à planter à à
planter énormément de de de résineux par
tous les moyens fallait des résineux il
fallait faire du bois avec les résineux
le matériel était pour les résineux et
donc petit à petit ça ça ça a été très
très vite quoi donc il y a une main mise
par les investisseurs qui était assez
terrible sur le Morvant et les
propriétaires morvend non n'ont pas
exemp de de reproche ils sont empressés
aussi de vendre leur forêt Lucienne est
une pionnière depuis 40 ans elle se bat
contre l'exploitation intensive de la
forêt c'est vraiment un spectacle de
désolation quoi ben il y a une coupace
de tout peuplement sur toute la parcelle
on est passé avec les gros engins c'est
l'exemple même de ce qui se passe dans
le Morvent et ailleurs c'est qu'en fait
là on coupe des forêts de feuillu on
aurait très bien pu éclaircir ou faire
autre chose la couperass ça devrait être
une décision ultime c'est quand on peut
plus faire autrement on fait une
coupprince mais pas quand on a d'autres
solutions celle qu'on surnomme
affectueusement lu du Morvent est devenu
le visage de ce combat pour sauver la
forêt
traditionnelle la représentation de ce
qui'est une belle forêt ici quand on
s'est battu pour le domaine de mon main
moi chaîne il m'a tout de suite plu quoi
il onont dit c'est le chaînne à Lulu
parce que ce chaîne moi d'abord je je
dis que mes centes jeux qu'elle soit
mise au pied de ce chînne il est
magnifique et c'est le symbole vraiment
de la lutte pour sauver le domaine de
mon main moi c'est toute mon histoire
depuis mon enfance ils sont même pas ici
les industriels voulaient faire de la
forêt de Montmain une monoculture de
raésineux imaginons ici cette beauté de
la forêt complètement en raésiné une
monoculture de douglasse c'est terrible
vous avez une forêt il y a plus rien qui
vit
dessous alors Lucienne a créé le premier
groupement forestier citoyen des femmes
et des hommes qui s'unissent pour
acheter la forêt et la gérer de manière
durable ensemble ils ont pu sauver ce
domaine et vous savez la forêt elle est
pas
simplement un produit de c'est pas un
produit de bois consommable à foison la
forêt c'est aussi pour les sols la
qualité des sols pour l'eau c'est très
lié à la
biodiversité on dit ah B oui ben le
changement climatique alors c'est sûr
qu'il existe mais les monocultures des
des d'pica si les épica avaient été
plantés en mélange avec des feuilleux et
tout on serait pas obligé de tout
ratiboiser moi j'en veux à la politique
forestière en ha lieu au ministère parce
que à nos élus parce que les loiselles
sont votées par nos députés par nos
sénateurs et qu'est-ce qu'ils font
qu'est-ce qu'ils font jusqu'à maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'ils font devant C
l'impact climatique qu'est-ce qu'on
essaie de faire pour aller euh du pour
limiter la ce à 82 ans sa révolte et son
engagement reste
intact les écologistes se battent depuis
des années contre les monocultures et
les couprase pour permettre aux forêts
de mieux résister au changement
climatique une idée qui commence à faire
son chemin chez certains forestiers
comme ici dans la
Nièvre on peut parevenir sur le passé ce
qui a été fait ça ça c'est des
plantations qui datent de entre 40 et 60
ans oui alors c'est des erreurs jusqu'à
tant que il ait les mortalités on disait
pas que c'était des erreurs parce que
c'était un schéma qui fonctionnait qui
était rentable mais aujourd'hui
manifestement bon voilà on sait qu'on
est plus dans le vrai donc
c'est important d'en tenir compte et
puis puis à nous d'évoluer maintenant je
reconnais aussi que les écologistes ont
fait évoluer ont participé à faire
évoluer les mentalités c'est une bonne
chose mais aujourd'hui on est un stade
où justement les Forestiers ont pris
conscience de certaines choses et l'idée
c'est c'est pe-être plutôt de d'être
dans la discussion et dans les échanges
plutôt que de critiquer systématiquement
tout Alexandre couvenant gère des forêts
de petits propriétaires privés sur cette
parcelle abattre les 30 hectares de
peuplier et de
freine les arbres sont presque tous
morts de sécheresse ou d'un champignon
la
calarose seules les chaînes sont
épargnées le coupe ras c'est pas un
choix c'est voilà c'est c'est quelque
chose de subi hein mais c'est sûr qu'on
aurait préféré faire une coupe
d'éclairci hein parce que c'est ce qu'on
pratique en temps normal
euh pour faire juste
profiter les arbres d'avenir et et après
à terme récolter du bois d'œuvre et là
actuellement c'est pas possible
l'intervention est trop risquée pour les
bûcherons alors Alexandre a fait appel à
une
abatteuse c'est un travail qui est très
dangereux lorsqu'il y a des bois secs et
donc il faut faut du matériel B robuste
et même si on trouve que c'est gros mais
c'est la seule façon pour pour pouvoir
exploiter ce type de
bois ce bois n'aurait dû être récolté
que dans 20 ans il a perdu toute sa
[Musique]
valeur il y a uniquement les quelques
résineux qui vont partir en Syrie mais
c'est vraiment anecdotique sinon le
freine va partir en bois de chauffage et
le
peuplier va être transformé soit en
panneau de particule ou en
OSB éventuellement
papier face à cette situation Alexandre
est
démuni il a beau diversifier ses forêts
travailler en fut irrégulière avec
plusieurs essences d'arbres de
différentes tailles qui récolte petit à
petit ils sont quand même malades
aujourd'hui en voulant faire pour le
mieux on est sûr de rien c'est vraiment
terrible quoi al s'adapter c'est une
certitude savoir quel essence m avec
certitude c'est impossible donc on va on
va faire des essais on va essayer d'y
croire c'est difficile oui ou c'est
c'est sûr que c'est difficile parce que
voilà forcément on croit moins dans dans
ce qu'on fait donc c'est on a envie d'y
croire mais on sait que autant nos
prédécesseurs ils ont voilà il plant il
se POS pas la question et ça allit au
bout il travaill forêt tel qu' savait le
faire et ça fonctionnait aujourd'hui ben
même en étant se posant beaucoup de
questions on est sûr de rien on voulant
faire pour le mieux on est sûr de rien
quoi
donc voilà c'est très c'est
c'est c'est pas facile à
[Musique]
vivre la filière n'a plus le choix elle
doit s'adapter et trouver un équilibre
entre économie et
[Musique]
écologie en
Auvergne même le sapin pourtant
endémique ne résiste plus les
changements climatiques vont très vite
trop vite à l'échelle de
l'arbre Christian et Chantal ont hérité
de plusieurs petites parcelles de
forêt VO sont toujours en train de qui
sont en train de mourir là et ça gagne
en fait dépérissement en fait ce celui
aussi c'est
C conseillé par leur coopérative
forestière sur cette parcelle d'un
hectare le couple a décidé de couper
l'ensemble des sapins malades pour
replanter d'autres
espèces il y a du
comort plus loin il y a du douglas alors
leOM on le voit il a bien bien
pris c'est un Paris sur
l'avenir c'est
un on n pas une science exacte voilà et
donc il faut il faut essayer il faut
innover il faut mélanger il faut
utiliser tous les modes de culture qui
existe pour savoir lequel à un moment
donné en tirera son épingle du jeu et
permettra d'avoir une belle forêt pour
nos générations
futures sur d'autres parcelles de sapin
C forestiers de la coopérative ont fait
un choix différent il y a pas une
solution il y a pas une seule solution
quand on arrive devant un peuplement et
et et j'allais dire on peut proposer des
choses au
propriétaires soit en effet de récolter
parce que le propriétaire a peur pour la
suite de son peuplement et légitimement
soit en effet de de faire une éclairci
donc là la solution qu'on a mis en place
avec le propriétaire ça a été de
récolter uniquement les bois secs en
espérant que les sapins qui sont là
puissent ben encore continuer à
progresser un petit peu et puis en miser
un petit peu d'avenir sur sur eux malgré
voilà les effets qu'on connaît du
réchauffement climatique on aura moins
de souches qui vont pomper l'eau et donc
ceux qui sont là on espère qu'ils vont
en profiter le mieux possible il va
moins pleuvoir mais SS ils sont moins à
se partager l'eau on espère que ça va
pouvoir être une solution qui va leur
permettre de passer le cap après ce
qu'on a essayé de faire aussi c'est de
garder au maximum le le mélange
d'essence quelques essences qu'on avait
en accompagnement on les a favorisé on
voit on a un être un chînne un châignier
voilà peut-être c'est peut-être celui-ci
qui sera une aissance d'avenir sur ce
sur cette
parcelle en France 75 % de la forêt est
privée et elle est très
morcelée plus de 2 millions de
propriétaires possèdent moins d'un
hectare aucune réglementation ne
s'impose à eux car en dessous de 25
hectares chacun gère sa forêt comme il
veut il aura plus d'aiguill on est
malheureusement en période propriéire le
propriétaire forestier reste
complètement maître chez lui donc nous
proposons des choses au propriétaires
comme on a pu le voir aujourd'hui mais
jamais nous allons lui imposer quelque
chose donc un propriétaire qui voudrait
mettre une seule essence il est et qu'il
respecte la réglementation il serait
libre de le faire mais ce n'est plus ce
que vous conseillez actuellement c'est
généralement jamais ce qu'on conseille
sauf à ce que les parcelles soient
vraiment très petites et au quel cas le
fait de mettre plusieurs essences
pourrait vraiment compliqué la gestion
future de la
parcelle ça veut dire aussi qu'on arrête
les
coupases on va pas en finir avec les
couppras la futée régulière est un mode
de syviculture tout à fait valable comme
la futée irrégulière est un mode de
silviculture tout à fait valable et
comme comme on vous l'a beaucoup dit
aujourd'hui on faut pas mettre tous nos
dans le même panier alors on ne va
certainement plus faire de coupe de
récolte sur des dizaines et des dizaines
d'hectares comme ça a pu se faire à une
époque ça sans doute le ce serait un
mauvais conseil au propriétaires
forestiers SAU imp passe sylvicol dû par
exemple à des peuplements dépérissants
mais un peuplement qui qui pousse
normalement on va l'accompagner et s'il
y a des récoltes à faire on va plutôt
morceler ses récoltes que de le faire
sur des dizaines et des dizaines
d'hectares si la forêt ne réussit plus à
s'adapter seul comment
l'aider nous retrouvons Brigitte m la
généticienne de l'ONF près de
Dijon celui-là on voit très bien qu'il a
eu un souci et je me demande même s'il
est pas reparti il est reparti depuis
les dernières pluies elle pilote le
projet Giono un programme de migration
assisté les scientifiques ont introduit
des arbres qui ne poussaient pas
naturellement ici et du coup on a recréé
des bandes dans lesquelles on a planté
on est venu donc là il y a des chaînes
mais c'est des chaînes pubaissants ouis
c'est puant donc ça c'est des petits
chaînes pu baissant on voit bien là il y
a des petits poils et ces poils là ils
lui servent à
moins moins subir la le moins perdre
d'eau voilà moins subir l'air sec donc
c'est vraiment un intérêt c'est un
chaîne qui vient du sud de la
France de Provence et et du coup c'est
c'est une piste vraiment intéressante
pour nous ici et pour cette espèce en
particulier le le chaîn pubaissant on a
bien fait la migration insister donc
c'est une espèce qui est présente dans
le sud de de la France et que on a
apporté par main duc humainement
jusqu'ici avec un réchauffement s'il
avait été beaucoup beaucoup plus
progressif il aurait pu en plusieurs
milliers d'années dizaines de milliers
d'années potentiellement reconquérir
naturellement le nord de la France mais
c'est pas le cas on a déposé un projet
ils ont aussi planté des cèes Liban issu
des forêts du
Luberon remettre allez donc on aide la
nature à faire ce qu'elle aurait fait
classiquement et nous il faut qu'on mise
avec tout ce qu'on sait pour l'instant
de de la science des arts de la
foresterie et qu'on réinvente quelque
chose de nouveau pour continuer à avoir
une forêt qui rend tous ces services
écosystèm
l'ONF a aussi développé des îos d'avenir
sur des petites parcell il teste des
espèces exotiques qui n'étaient pas
présentes en France jusqu'à maintenant
sur celle-ci ils ont planté du calocèdre
c'est donc un résineux qui ressemble un
petit peu à un cyprè ou un tuyaa et il
est originaire il est originaire de la
côte ouest des États-Unis Californie et
qui dans des conditions d'origine montre
une très bonne résistance à la
sécheresse tout en étant dans des
conditions d'altitude a de la neige
l'hiver du du grand froid ce sont des
espèces pour lesquelles on connaît pas
forcément grand-chose qui on pas été
introduitite largement en France et en
Europe et donc on a besoin de référence
à la fois sur le taux de survie sur la
croissance sur la pétance au au gibier
la résistance au stress
hydrique pas question pour autant de
jouer aux apprentis sorcier l'espèce est
très
surveillée on a potentiellement toujours
un risque pour la biodiversité et c'est
pour ça que on a introduit ces espèces
de manière expérimentale et on va
regarder comment il interagit avec
l'écosystème autour et en particulier
les problèmes d'invasivité qui sont le
problème majeur des espèces exotiques
après on ne va pas couvrir la forêt avec
du du calocadre mais ça fait partie du
panel d'espèces que l'on pourra proposer
à un peu plus grande échelle que un demi
heectare dans quelques
forêts entre les
dépérissement et les nouvelles essences
dans 50 ans le visage de nos forêts va
évoluer nos paysages vont changer mais
si on a comme on le prévoit une mé TER
anisation de la forêt plus au au nord
hein on va avoir une forêt
méditerranéenne donc des des arbres qui
vont être plus petits aussi donc ça il
faut vraiment s'attendre à des arbres
plus petits et à des productions de bois
de moins
importantes loin de cette forêt du futur
dans le Morvent Lucienne et son
association tente aussi à leur façon de
préserver la forêt et sa biodiversité
bon Lucienne tu la trouves comment ta
forêt trouve belle les souches regarde
si c'est beau ça gêne pas pour exploiter
et en plus c'est la biodiversité
formidable
quoi en 20 ans Lucienne et le groupement
forestier ont racheté 20 forêts 350ar au
total qu'ils ont confié à
tristus l'expert gère et exploite les
arbres car la forê n'est pas sous cloche
elle a aussi un rôle
regarde on alors ici on applique un
traitement en futé dit irrégulière c'est
en fait c'est une gestion forestière qui
doit répondre à des intérêts économiques
et écologiques donc on cherche à avoir
sur cette forêt différentes essences
maintenir les essences qui sont
présentes notamment le H le chîn il y a
du boulot il y a un peu de résineux et
on cherche à avoir une structuration du
peuplement c'estàdire des petits arbres
des moyens des gros et des très gros
arbres alors économiquement bien sûr sû
c'est viable ça rapporte peut-être moins
d'argent dans les premiers temps mais au
fur à mesure ça va rapporter de l'argent
et ça c'est un modèle qui est
transposable alors nous c'est un modèle
qu'on essaie de transposer sur toutes
les forêts en France ça soit du pain
maritime ça soit du sapin ça soit du ça
soit du chne y a pas longtemps pour eux
c'est la seule façon d'avoir des forêts
plus résiliantes face au changement
climatique ils aimeraient que ce modèle
devienne la norme et moi franchement je
suis émerveillé de voir le résultat et
je suis fre d'avoir participer à à à ça
quoi je me dis mais tu as pas perdu ton
temps quand tu t'es battu il faut passer
un message quand même d'optimiste quoi
parce que si on commence à dire tout est
foutu la forêt commence à être malade
les ares tous malades les plantations sa
pas si elles vont tenir ou pas B c'est
quand même assez terrible quoi on peut
pas se passer de la forêt c'est pas
possible mais si le G dit dans 50 ans
augmentation de température de 4
degr que ça soit du résinux que ça soit
du feuillu mon avis il y aura plus
d'armes ça c'est clair mais alors c'est
terrible quoi de penser ça parce que les
générations futures les enfants et tout
mais comment on peut faire de vivre dans
un monde stérile moi je veux pas y
croire je dis que quand même tous
ensemble on peut avancer quoi moi je dis
qu'il faut faire le moins mal possible
[Musique]
voilà aider la forêt à se régénérer par
elle-même à s'adapter
gétiquement préserver son sol sa
diversité d'essence et donc sa
biodiversité autant de défis pour sauver
la forêt pour qu'elle continue de
stocker du carbone et reste notre poumon
vert